what is the difference between Saka and
zakat by definition zakat means to
purify to increase it means goodness it
means blessing and satka comes from the
root word s which means sincerity so it
is the sincerity in faith of Allah
subhana
taala zakat by definition According to
Islamic Sharia is an obligatory charity
which every Muslim who owns more than
the nisab level or Surplus wealth if he
has it with him for a year period he has
to give 2.5% on it every year as far as
satka is concerned it is an optional
charity Zak is also worship of Allah
obeying the command of Allah subh tala s
is also worship of Allah it's obeying
Allah but it is voluntary the major
differences between zakat and S is that
there are certain conditions is required
for zakat number one it is given on
certain
goods for example gold
silver ornaments containing gold or
silver
merchandise it can be business
activities Farm produce cattle and all
the categories whereas satka you don't
have to possess any wealth that you have
to give satka it can be just given s
Point number two in zakat these
properties and Surplus wealth should be
with you for one full year then you have
to give zakat s there's no necessity of
any particular wealth being with you for
such and such a period you can just give
it without any time period Point number
three you should have a nisab level of
these wealth only when nisab level for
example if you have gold weighing 85 G
then you have to give zakat or silver 5
95 G if it less than that no
irrespective of the property you have
less more irrespective you can give
voluntary the other differen is zakat
can only be given to the eight
categories who are permitted to receive
zakat in the Quran Surah TBA chapter
number 9 verse number 60 the poor people
the needy Etc which we discussed earlier
s it can be given to anyone it can be
given to the categor of zakat it can be
given to the category outside zakat
there's no limitation no binding
whatsoever
Point number five if a person who is
liable to pay zakat and does not pay
zakat and he dies then his children
his have to see to it that the zakat is
paid off if it's from his property
before Distributing the wealth it should
be paid off that's a liability which is
not the case of satka person who intends
to do satka and dies his head need not
fulfill that it is his own intention if
they want they can it's
optional number six
if you don't give zakat which is the
pillar of Islam obligation it's
compulsory you'll be punished for that
as Allah says in Surah chter 9 verse
number 3435 you'll be
banded with the fire from hell with that
gold on which you haven't paid zakat
which is not the case in sadka point
number
seven zakat cannot be given to the Des
ofi wasallam which is not the kid with
satka you can give it to the prophet
also and to his family Point number
eight you cannot give zakat to the
dependents a father can't give to the
son a person can't give to his father
whereas s a father can give to a son a
son can give to the father
irrespectively depending or
not Point number
nine zakat in most categories cannot be
given to the rich and the
healthy can be given to the rich and the
healthy zakat cannot be given to the
non-muslims
can be non Muslims so these are the
major 1 differences between zakat and S
well thank you very much Dr Zak